Omarosa says she's got tapes Jim Acosta
and Jim Acosta makes a mockery of
himself once more and the Oscars decided
to answer things up I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show you know is a
long night when you come in hot like
that right off the top just really solid
stuff to open the show right there by
blowing the intro so that's what happens
when the alarm goes off in your house
and 1:00 in the morning and you're just
creeping around your house trying not to
wake up your kids and 1:00 in the
morning and then of course it turns out
that it's all a malfunction I do
actually have news to get to today but I
have to remind you that next week we are
actually taking our show on the road to
audiences in Dallas in Phoenix
okay it's next week each venue is almost
entirely sold out if you have not yet
gotten your tickets head over to Live
Nation calm or Ticketmaster calm search
Ben Shapiro you don't want to miss it
it's gonna be a blast and I can't wait
to see you there also I want to remind
you that if you need to relax okay if
you've just been stressed out over the
summer stressed out about the news about
your job well the best way to ensure
that your stress is alleviated is by
heading over to Zeile calm because Zeile
is the place where you can get a massage
on demand you don't have to go to a spy
enough to wait in line and have to pay
exorbitant prices Zeile comm ensures
that you can select from top local
licensed and pre-screened massage
therapists you choose your favorite
technique gender preference time and
location for your massage and Zeile will
then send one of their 10,000 licensed
massage therapists with the massage
table music and supplies to give you a
five-star massage scheduling booking
payment fast and easy even the tip has
included seven days a week 365 days a
year
as 'il massage therapists can be at your
door in as little as an hour it's
privacy its convenience its quality its
comfort I've gotten zeal for my wife for
my parents for my sister for my
mother-in-law legitimately everyone my
family has you zeal one point or another
because it is just great and you can do
it on the spur of the moment to help you
get started our listeners can get twenty
five bucks off their first massage with
promo code been again that seals EEE
Elcom promo code bent right now go to
zeal comm or the iPhone or Android app
get that special offer when you try seal
today again promo code bond you get 25
bucks off your first in-home massage
they bring the spa to you it is just
great so go check that out
okay so chaos continues to reign inside
the Trump administration despite the
fact that the situation in the United
States is good the economy is very solid
we're not in mesh in any serious foreign
crises the chaos that has been caused
the staffing of this administration just
continues to resonate the latest stories
that Amuro semana Gault who never should
have been anywhere near the Oval Office
has tapes inside the Oval Office which
who would have suspected that from her
crazy appearances on The Apprentice
who'd have suspected that the woman who
played a villain on The Apprentice would
actually end up taping Donald Trump
Donald Trump has suspected pretty much
every one of taping him but it turns out
that the two people who actually did
tape him are his own lawyer and Omarosa
Manigault according to The Daily Beast
Michael Cohen Donald Trump's personal
attorney and fixer isn't the only one
with secretly recorded audio of the
president multiple sources with direct
knowledge of the situation
tell The Daily Beast @ Omarosa Manigault
the infamous former apprentice star who
followed Trump to the White House
secretly recorded conversations with the
president conversations his since
leveraged while shopping her tell-all
book which is titled unhinged right
she's going to make every buck that she
can off of being associated with Trump
shoes and nobody when Trump found her
she's gonna be a nobody again but not
before she makes trouble for President
Trump by suggesting she has tapes of all
the worst things Trump has ever said I'm
not sure honestly what you could catch
him on tape doing that would be worse
than what he has tweeted but I guess
we're gonna find out for months it has
been rumored that Manigault has
clandestinely recorded on her smartphone
tapes of unspecified private discussions
she had in the West Wing
audio actually does exist and even stars
Trump one person confirmed to The Daily
Beast they'd heard at least one of the
recordings multiple sources said that
the recorded conversations are anodyne
everyday chatter but they did appear to
feature at Trump's voice which grants
her additional credibility in pumping
her book the media of course will treat
her with all sorts of respect there's
there's a phenomenon in the media where
if you rip on a Republican figure and
you were once a friend with the
Republican figure then you get this sort
of grand new respect a strange new
respect suddenly you are taken very
seriously if you used to work in the
Trump administration and then you turn
on Trump you're Michael Cohen then all
the sudden numbers ago Michael Cohen
great truth teller really good guy
Omarosa who everyone despises suddenly
Omarosa
is a wonderful person again but but it
does demonstrate that when President
Trump says that he staffs up with the
best people and not so much as a
flashback to president from tweeting
just five years ago quote honest Omarosa
she won't backstab she'll come at you
from the front unless she's recording
you like with her phone in her pocket so
none of that is particularly good
meanwhile
Giuliani is on the road trying to gin up
support for the president in the Muller
investigation as I had suggested before
the idea of putting Donald Trump in a
room with Robert Muller is the height of
stupidity there is no way in hell that
the President of the United States
should sit down with Robert Muller he
doesn't have a legal obligation to do so
according to Supreme Court rulings
there's a Supreme Court ruling in US
versus Nixon which suggests that the
President of the United States can be
subpoenaed for evidence if there's
physical evidence like the Watergate
tapes then he can be subpoenaed for that
but it is absolutely unclear whether the
President of the United States has to
sit down with members of the Justice
Department which he runs and then order
the FBI which he is the head of that is
unclear at best right now
Trump is negotiating with Muller to sit
down with him apparently Rudy says that
if Trump sits down with Muller Rudy
Guiliani of course being Trump's lawyer
Rudy says that if Trump sits down with
Muller they shouldn't cover two topics
the firing of James Comey and the
discussions about Michael Flynn regard
with with James Comey as you recall
Michael Flynn was the president's former
national security adviser after he was
fired James Comey suggested that he
might be prosecuted the President of the
United States said to him that he would
like it if Comey could find his way
clear to letting Flynn off the hook
because he's a good guide nothing ever
really came of that and then of course
he fired Jim's call me the suggestion
here is that Trump doesn't want to talk
to Muller about issues of obstruction of
justice because there are really three
areas in which Trump bears possible
legal liability two of them I think are
particularly weak so the first one is
that Trump theoretically could be caught
up in a conspiracy charge conspiracy
charge involves you and I decide that
we're gonna rob a bank so we got
together and we make a plan to rob a
bank we have now come into conspiracy to
rob the bank but there has to be an
underlying crime there has to be
something we were going to do that was
criminal or if you and I got together
and we drop a conspiracy to go down to
the grocery store and shop that is not a
crime because there is no underlying
crime well the question is whether there
was an underlying crime in which the
President of the United States was
involved the evidence there is not good
okay then there's no evidence whatsoever
that Trump either knew about any
conspiracy between the Trump team and
the Russian government or even that a
conspiracy between team Trump and the
Russian government was was happening
insofar as a criminal conspiracy because
it's not clear that it's actually
criminal for Team Trump to get for
example Oppo
info on Hillary Clinton now does that
mean it's good no that doesn't mean that
it's good but it doesn't mean that it's
illegal not quite the same thing legal
charges are not the same thing as doing
bad things as a lot of people found out
with regard to Hillary Clinton it turns
out that destroying a server that you
create may not actually be legally
prosecuted but it is still a bad thing
to do and you may lose an election
because of it so that's area number one
is the conspiracy area area number two
is the obstruction area and here the
idea would be that if the President of
the United States tried to shut down the
mall our investigation or tried to
obstruct the mall or investigation in
any way then perhaps you can bring a
charge that's really weak because Trump
is the head of the executive branch even
fired Miller tomorrow that wouldn't
actually be obstruction obstruction
would be if he tried to hide evidence or
if there was a pending judicial
proceeding and he tried to bribe
somebody or if you want to Muller and he
ordered him to come up with a particular
result on the investigation
so obstruction is weak sauce unless
Trump goes in front of Moeller and says
in front of Muller that he intended to
fire James Comey to stop the
investigation if he says that then you
have a pretty cut-and-dry obstruction
charge that would be a serious problem
for president Trump which is why Trump
doesn't want to talk to Muller about any
of that and then finally you have the
biggest issue for Trump which is why he
shouldn't talk to Miller at all and that
is lying to the FBI the president has an
unfortunate habit of of saying
everything that comes into his head he
has a severe case of dysentery of the
mouth and it's just diarrhea overflow of
the mouth and when he is in front of a
lawyer that is a really bad problem as I
said on Fox yesterday on Kennedy show if
you are a person who wants to be taken
seriously but not literally don't go
into law law is all about taking people
literally not just seriously Trump says
a lot of stuff where we all kind of go
yeah that's just trumping Trump lawyers
don't do that particularly prosecutor so
Trump would be foolish to sit down with
Robert Motherwell Rudy Giuliani was on
with Sean Hannity yesterday and Hannity
asked him like why are you even having
these talks in the first place why is
this even happening Giuliani said the
reality is the real story is that this
case isn't going to fizzle it's gonna
blow up on them the real question is
what we talked about before there's a
lot more to what they did that nobody
knows about yet a lot more to the
obstruction of justice to the collusion
to the fake dossier Kennedy said I know
some of it which is not particularly
surprising since he coordinates with the
Trump administration a lot and Giuliani
said can it get any worse I mean what do
we need to know that this is it
illegitimate investigation based on a
report a dossier that was paid for by
Hillary Clinton and the Democrats so
Sean asks the the correct question which
is okay well then why don't you just
fire Mahler and if this whole thing is
illegitimate why don't you fire him and
why would you talk about sitting down
with team Muller and Giuliani
essentially said well we know there
would be political blowback also if this
thing is not over by September it's
going to be a problem so it's it's yeah
I'm not sure the team Trump has the
greatest strategy here but Giuliani can
only do as a lawyer what his what his
client wants him to do all of that said
these are criminal questions this is not
the political question the political
question is how much this affects the
Republican Party going into the midterm
elections in 2018 a lot of Trump fans
think all this stuff doesn't have any
impact on congressional elections I'm
very skeptical of that point of view
there's a good piece by seán trend over
at Real Clear Politics today talking
about the the actual statistical trends
going into the 2018 elections he says
the results on Tuesday night which we
talked about here yesterday in Ohio's
12th congressional district and across
the country the results weren't fully
consistent with a democratic wave in the
house washing up on our shores in
November well there's still time between
now and then there's not a lot of time
and we're at the point where these
elections start to be suggestive if not
fully predictive start with Ohio this is
a Republican district overall it leans
Republican by seven points they're
around 60 GOP hell districts that are
less Republican than this one a Democrat
has won this area of the state just once
since the Great Depression the last time
the seat was open in 2000 the Republican
won by 10 points and the district has
made substantially Republican since then
in short Democrats had no business being
competitive here even with a good
candidate in O Connor so what happened
two things first turnout was down in the
rural portions of the districts compared
to the urban areas that means that Trump
voters didn't show up in Ohio Franklin
County which is Columbus cast around 35
percent of the vote Tuesday as compared
to 32 percent in 2016 but that means
greater energy on the Democratic side
second Democrat vote share was up in
urban and suburban areas these are all
the voters the president Trump has been
alienating in suburban areas Franklin
County was a different story this
portion of the district contains a lot
of the older suburbs of Columbus places
people moved to in the 70s and 80s to
Barry won 59 percent of the vote here
bothersome 135 percent to Barry was the
candidate the Republican candidate
before ball derson so the
verbs the Republicans are just falling
off in a serious way Shawn trend who's a
very good elections analyst he concludes
this isn't a great sign for the GOP the
Democrats combined to run three points
ahead of Republicans in the eighth
District something of a Seattle analog
to Ohio's 12th is beatle Washington 8th
district of more concern for the GOP
Republicans ran only a half point ahead
of Democrats in the third district which
leans Republican by about four points so
it could be bad stuff for Republicans
come November which is why they really
need to focus in on the issues and it's
not like they don't have something to
work with it's not like they're on
something to work with I want to talk
about what congressional elections
really revolve around in just one second
but first let's talk about your
underwear when it comes to comfort down
below there is underwear and then there
is Tommy John the revolutionary clothing
brand that is redefined comfort for
Americans everywhere including me I wear
Tommy John underwear and they are just
fantastic Tommy John's is not give
enough they give three EPs fabric fit
and function Tommy John obsessions
obsesses over every little detail and
stitch by using proprietary fabrics that
perform like nothing you've ever worn
before
as a result Tommy John's men's and
women's underwear support and no wedgie
guarantee comfortable stay put waist
bands a range of fabrics that are
luxuriously soft feather-light moisture
wicking breathable designed to move with
you not against you which means no
bunching no riding up the wedgie
guarantee would have been very helpful
to me in high school
Tommy Tron is so confident in their
underwear that if you don't love your
first pair you can get a full refund but
the best pair you'll ever wear or it's
free guarantee this includes the new
life changing women's underwear they
sold those things out in just six weeks
but now it's fully back in stock so go
check it out Tommy John comm / Shapiro
for 20% off your first order that's
Tommy John comm / Shapiro for 20% off
your first order again Tommy John comm /
Shapiro they make the best underwear in
the country go check them out right now
Tommy John comm / Shapiro ok so what
have these congressional elections
actually work there's this misnomer that
all politics is local
when it comes to congressional elections
it's all about the local election I have
a question for you
how many of you actually know who your
Congress person is I would wager that
vary there they're outside most people
who vote in elections probably don't
even know who their Congress person is
or if they do know they don't know much
about them people use mental shortcuts
to determine for whom they're going to
vote they use the R or the D a lot more
than they use the name of the candidate
in their particular district which is
why
it is very indicative of whether a
district will go in one direction or
another what the constituency of that
district is when are +10 district it
almost doesn't matter who the candidate
is the Republicans should win unless
what you are seeing is a wave against
Republicans this means that all
elections are national okay one of the
great lies that we've been told about
politics is that all politics is local
because of the prevalence of media
because most people who are engaged in
politics are reading newspapers or
listening to shows like this one or
watching Fox News or CNN all elections
are basically nationalized at this point
which is why Republicans swept through
in 2020 in 2010 on a national platform
write national tea party platform and
it's why right now Republicans who are
running locally in the hopes that they
can avoid the stigma of Trump they have
a problem it's why Trump is a problem
for them Trump is a drag on a lot of
these Republican congressional tickets
he is not a boost to them because he is
the national issue now the Republicans
do have national issues they can
campaign on it's the same national issue
they campaigned on in the Georgia sixth
District and that is Nancy Pelosi should
never be Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi is a full-on wild left disaster
the idea that she should be running
policy from the House of Representatives
is frightening and should be frightening
to a lot of folks why Republicans are
not running nationally the real answer
is because they feel like if they were
on nationally they're gonna get hit with
the Trump and president Trump is such a
volatile quantity that if you if you
cross president Trump there's a good
shot he'll going on Twitter and then
he'll knock you off with your own base
and the president really wants to
maintain Congress well it'd be helpful
in the next 90 days is for the president
not to be particularly loud not to be
particularly vocal and for Republicans
to campaign against Democrats as I said
yesterday if you want to win elections
you have to make Democrats the issue if
you want to lose elections make Trump
the issue right now President Trump is
the issue and it's a problem for
Republicans when Democrats become the
issue when Alexandra Ocasio Cortez is
the headline of the day that's really
good for Republicans and you're actually
seeing that in the polling right now the
the polling keeps opening and closing
there's this gap that keeps opening and
closing and opening and closing that's
very reminiscent of 2016 when Hillary
Clinton would open these big gaps
against President Trump and then within
days they would close up again because
the question was who was it who was the
referendum on was it on Trump comes on
Trump Hillary got a lead if the
referendum was a Hilton referendum on
Hillary the lead went away and that
means the Republic
must turn every issue to the Nancy
Pelosi and Alexandra kasnia Cortez and
Tom Perez and Keith Ellison and the
radicalism of the Democratic Party
that's why I keep hammering this issue
now speaking of Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
you'll remember that yesterday on the
show I offered money out of my own
pocket to sponsor a debate with
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez or even a Sunday
special with Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
shockingly we have not actually heard
back from the Ocasio Cortes campaign I
have my doubts that she is willing or
interested in talking about these issues
with anybody who can ask her a serious
question I think the reason for that is
probably because she says silly things
on a routine basis I mean the fact that
she was propped up is one of the great
minds of our time is astonishing to me
she the same left that said that Sarah
Palin was a doofus and a dunce and
mocked Sarah Palin inordinately I can
see Russia from my house a thing that
Sarah Palin never said and that became
the stigma of Sarah Palin Sarah Palin
was an idiot Michele Bachmann was an
idiot right we just kept hearing about
every Republican woman every Republican
one was an idiot these same people keep
praising Alexandra Ocasio Cortez as some
sort of world-beating genius when it
comes to politics she did in the
interview with Chris Cuomo Chris Cuomo
is not the world's toughest to interview
at least not with regard to Democrats
and he stumps her not because he's a
stump wood but because she legitimately
has no capacity to answer basic and
simple questions so for example she was
asked about how she's going to pay for
all of her government programs and she
described how Medicare is going to save
us all money this is an astonishing
statement made by a human whose brain
apparently is at least partly functional
here she is trying to explain to my
Medicare will save money see if you can
spot the flaw in her logic people talk
about the sticker shock of Medicare for
all they do not talk about the sticker
shock of our of the cost of our existing
system we're paying for the system we
Americans have the sticker shock of
health care as it is and we're also not
talking about is why aren't we
incorporating the cost of all the
funeral expenses of those who died
because they can't afford access to
health care that is part of the cost of
our system why don't we talk about the
cost of reduced productivity because of
people who need to go on disability
because of people who are not able to
participate in our economy because they
have accent because they are having ish
like diabetes or or they don't have
access to the health care that they need
I think at the end of the day we see
that this is not a pipe dream every
other developed nation in the world does
this why can't America and that is the
question that we need to ask okay that
is a lie that every other developed
nation in the world does this and to to
apply all of those rules to everything
else is just it's it's just not correct
it's just not correct the Washington
Post has given that claim before three
Pinocchio's by the way like that's just
it's just not true but my favorite part
of that clip is where she explains with
a straight face that one of the costs
that we don't take into account when we
look at our health care system is the
cost of funerals I just want to note
that even if you believe that Medicare
lengthens life which is a dubious
proposition there are studies that
suggest it does not even if you believe
that it does at the end of that life
everyone gets dead right death happens
it's a thing and everyone will have it
and then everyone will have a funeral
so funeral costs don't disappear when
Medicare is made universal that is a
very weird claim that is a very weird
claim indeed and then she claims that
Medicare is going to prevent lost
productivity and it's going to prevent
people from dying of the bt's they won't
have diabetes anymore I don't know what
she thinks Medicare is but it actually
is not a unicorn that poops health I
just don't even know what she's talking
about here but she again is the great
brain again this this you know the claim
that she makes here that all of these
things save money it's just it's not
correct the the idea that we saved two
trillion dollars of claim that Ocasio
courts has makes here better under three
Pinocchio's writing from the post that's
the claim that I'm specifically talking
about that Ocasio Cortes makes her the
the the best one the the best part of
this interview though was when she was
asked about the Democratic leadership
even Ocasio Cortes can't defend the fact
that Nancy Pelosi is the leader of the
House Democrats she gives an answer here
that is very much akin to the answer
that Miss South Carolina once gave about
maps in the Miss Universe contest and
the Miss USA contest when she was asked
about what kids need in schools and she
said she thinks they need maps they know
where the Iraq SAR that's that's like
the such as the Iraq's and that that's
what Alexandra Ocasio Cortez sounds like
right here she
the leader of no no she I mean speaker
or rather leader Pelosi hopefully you
know we'll see she's uh she is the
current leader of the party and I think
that the party absolutely does have its
leadership in the house we have our
leadership in in the Senate as well oh
thank you for that clarification brain
of the Democratic Party
how can Republicans not defeat this if
you cannot defeat this you don't deserve
to be in office and I don't mean to feed
her in a district that is very heavily
Democrat I'm eeen if you can't use this
to nationalize your message I honestly
don't know what you are doing making a
living from this particular area of
human life this isn't come on - come on
Medicare's gay we're not taking into
account funeral expenses what in the
world what I can't imagine why she won't
come on the Sunday special I can't I
can't imagine it okay before we go any
further let's talk about your hair and
the fact that you are losing it because
you are okay as you're getting older
you're looking at your dad you're gone
Wow do I really want to be the bald as
pops over there well if you don't then
you really need to go check out keeps
okay there is a solution there are two
clinically proven medications that
actually let you keep your hair now
they're inexpensive and easy to get you
don't need to lose that hair if you
don't want to and that's what keeps is
for for five minutes now and just a buck
a day you'll never have to worry about
hair loss again getting started with
keeps is really easy sign up takes less
than five minutes just answer a few
questions snap some photos a licensed
doctor remotely reviews your information
recommends the right treatment for you
all without ever leaving your couch
keeps offers generic versions are the
only two FDA approved hair loss products
out there something probably tried them
before but you've never gotten them this
easily for this price keeps it's only
ten bucks to 35 bucks a month plus now
you can get your first month for free
which is a hell of a deal for getting to
keep your hair there's no reason to put
it off any longer
stop hair loss today go check it out
receive your first month of treatment
for free go to keeps calm slash pen
that's ke EPS calm slash pen again free
month of treatment at keeps calm slash
Ben you're getting the drugs that that
you know are the ones that the FDA
approves and you're getting them for a
cheaper price so really have nothing to
lose
keeps calm slash Ben go check it out
right now
Katie EPS calm slash up then it keeps
his hair today and here tomorrow okay so
meanwhile the other issue that
Republicans should be campaigning on is
obviously the the self involvement of
the media always a big winner for
Republicans and the leader in this
particular category is
Casta who that dude loves him some Jim
Acosta I mean whoo does Jim Acosta love
Jim Acosta so last night he was on
Stephen Colbert show now I would just
like to make a note about people who
don't believe in media bias Jim Acosta
is on is on Stephen Colbert show pod
save America which is a podcast that
does similar or smaller numbers than
this podcast has its own outlet on HBO
when do you think HBO is going to come
a-callin it's not a complaint we do find
here I mean we don't need HBO's money
but if you don't think there's a media
bias the fact that Jim Acosta in
Alexandria cosmically has been on
Colbert and we have never received a
single phone call from a late night show
is sort of and it's not just us I mean
you're never going to see any of the
major host on the right ever invited on
any of these late-night shows because
these late-night host don't actually
want to have to have an argument with
these folks they just want to invite on
fellow lefties that they can talk with
and feel comfortable with Jim Acosta who
is definitely not definitely not a self
aggrandizing jerk Jim Acosta is
definitely not a self infatuated person
right he's certainly not a guy who
believes himself to be the great savior
of the media he is certainly just
fighting for you the people he tweeted
this out getting ready to bring some
hashtag real news to Colbert Late Show
with Stephen at home hashtag not the
enemy and then it's a picture of him
looking in the mirror at himself which
okay first of all he actually there's
somebody else taking this picture right
he has to have a Seth
somebody else is in the room with him
staged this photo so if he can look like
it never occurs to him how
self-aggrandizing an arrogant this looks
that somebody that's what's amazing the
the truly incredible part of this
particular photo is the fact that Jim
Acosta is looking at Jim Acosta in the
mirror smiling smugly to himself and he
handed somebody his phone presumably to
take that well-lit picture of him
looking like a hero looking into the
mirror I mean the funny part of this is
that Jim Acosta sees himself looking in
the mirror and he sees Superman and the
rest of us see that guy from from The
Hangover who's lost his front tooth
looking in the mirror right that's the
that's that's really what this is and
the other part of this tweet that's just
great is he says he's gonna bring some
real news to Colbert Late Show his
Stephen Colbert is legitimately a
satirist
it's a late-night show so he's gonna
bring real news real News is going on
The Colbert Late Show so what exactly
did Jim Acosta say on the show
we've been looking everywhere for this
video but here is what he actually said
he actually said this and thought it was
an intelligent thing to say which is an
amazing thing he said all of our anchors
are photographers around the world our
producers some of my fellow reporters
who go into war zones and put their
lives on the line they're not the enemy
of the people okay that's fair but then
he says this my colleagues at ABC CBS
NBC and yes Fox News they're not in the
they're not the enemy of the people
either in a government that is of the
people by the people and for the people
there's no such thing as an enemy of the
people that last sentence makes no sense
at all and the fact that he had to think
about that and write that up and
memorize it beforehand that doesn't make
any sense if the media were actually
part of the government at least the
argument makes sense although that is
that suggests that there are people in
the government who can never be enemies
of the people which i think is blatantly
untrue there are plenty of governments
all over the world that are enemies of
their own people but that last line that
a government that is of the people by
the people and for the people there's no
such thing as an enemy of the people you
know we used to say that you know whose
line that is by the people for the
people of the people that that is a line
from Abraham Lincoln who legitimately
jail journalists so there's that but
also the the idea again the idea that
the media and the government are one and
the same is sort of the problem here
because the media and the government are
one in the same until it comes time to
critique a Republican then all of a
sudden they are the watchdogs on the
front lines of truth and Jim Acosta man
the media just doing what they can to
demonstrate that they are completely out
of touch with the American people and
speaking of out of touch with the
American people untuk briefly on the on
Hollywood for just a second so Hollywood
made an announcement yesterday that they
are changing the Oscars so what are they
doing well they're going to focus on a
three hour broadcast because right now
it's approximately 37 hours the Oscars I
think the last time I actually watched a
full Oscar telecast it's got to have
been at least 10 years since I watched a
full Oscar telecast because why in the
world would you and one of the reasons
nobody watches the Oscars anymore is
because every film that is nominated is
basically which is the most social
justice warrior film so last year was
the shape of water which was a social
justice film about a woman having sex
with a fish and her little gang of
friends who were going to help fight the
American government with the help of I
am not kidding you this is the plot of
the shape of water a communist doctor a
gay man and a black woman who was put
upon by her husband
right and these well these will be and
the and the woman who is the the main
character is a deaf me is a mute she's
not she's not deaf that is the actual
plot of the shape of water it's a
terrible terrible film at one Best
Picture it's it's it's splash if somehow
that film had fallen on its head as a
baby that's the shape of water is and I
don't say this with any animus toward
the actors I mean I think that Nick
Searcy who's in the film is a friend but
the film is just absolute hogwash and
garbage the only doubt was whether that
was going to win or whether they'll call
me by your name a movie about a 27 year
old dude seducing a 17 year old kid
whether that was male kid whether that
was going to win Best Picture so every
year at social justice warrior films
that nobody has actually seen and then
they wonder why they're losing ratings
so how did they decide to combat this do
they decide to combat this by actually
nominating some films that people wanted
to see you know big blockbuster films
that people actually like watching like
for example I believe the Dark Knight
was nominated for Best Picture in 2008
that's the last time a really popular
film was nominated for Best Picture was
probably 10 years ago like a real
blockbuster film I'm old enough to
remember when Lord of the Rings all
three films were nominated for Best
Picture would those be nominated today I
can't imagine they would be I can't
imagine they would be the only the only
filmmaker who is even somewhat
commercial who whose films will be
nominated anymore is Christopher Nolan
and even he has not won a Best Director
Oscar which is just insane
instead you'll get pictures like
moonlight winning right even even lala
land which is an artsy film that did
well at the box office even there it
lost to moonlight a store a
coming-of-age story about a gay black
kid so the Oscars have been kind of out
of touch with uh the American people are
actually interested in paying money to
see at the theaters for a long time so
how are they fixing this well the way
that they are fixing this is they're
creating a new category designed around
achievement in popular film which
automatically implies that there's also
achievements in unpopular film right
achievement and unpopular film that's
the stuff that Hollywood likes to make
and then achievement in popular film is
the stuff where basically they're gonna
do the MTV Movie Awards or it's like oh
here's where we nominate Black Panther
and here's where we nominate Thor
Ragnarok and here's where we nominate
the Avengers films right we'll put all
the superhero films in one category and
we'll pretend that they're not actually
quality and then we'll have all of our
quality films that no one saw but that
we feel make us special a cocktail
parties and this is because Hollywood is
an insular in insular little island all
to itself in the same way that the media
have become this insular little island
all the way for itself it's so stupid in
every way it's basically an
acknowledgment that the folks in
Hollywood hate you that they are taking
your money to make movies like Mission
Impossible and then they're taking some
of that money and siphoning it off into
the real projects they care about the
story of the lesbian transgender little
person who overcame all odds to become
the head of a prostitution ring right
that's legitimately that that's almost
the plot of that film that Scarlett
Johansson was supposed to star in and no
one would have seen except that Scarlett
Johansson was in it my favorite part of
that story by the way is that the social
justice warriors killed that film
outright because they said Scarlett
Johansson should not star in it and now
that film will never get made it never
gets distributed so just spectacular
it's so stupid in every way they're not
gonna they're not they're not gonna
focus on making stuff that people want
to see they're gonna continue to
separate off the stuff they want to make
from the stuff people want to see and
then patronize the audience by
suggesting here is the award for the
rubes and then here is the award for
those of us who really really matter
also let's be real about this the real
reason they're creating this new
category so black panther can win an
Oscar right that's that's really why
they are creating this new category I
didn't think of creating this new
category three years ago but they think
black panther oughta win an Oscar and
legitimately I don't see why black
panther shouldn't be nominated for an
Oscar like in the regular category it's
a good movie it's a fine movie I liked
the movie I had some problems with it
but overall I thought it was one of the
better Marvel flicks but yeah again
Hollywood is completely out of touches
well this out of touch this is something
this culture war is something where the
Republicans really could do some serious
damage if they chose to do so speaking
of the culture war and you play this
clip from my love Kunis because it
really does suggest how broadly the
culture war has spread and it has some
relevance to the conversations we are
now having about race in the country
believe it or not but first you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wire.com to
subscribe so for $9.99 a month get the
rest of the show live get the rest of
Clavin show live in Knowles's show live
we have some brand new stuff that is
coming for subscribers I can't wait to
tell you about it but if I tell you
about it my business partner will murder
me because I legitimately forward cast
things two years in advance see aka the
Shapiro store so the but the bottom line
is there's all sorts of good stuff
coming if you become a member also
you're helping us out nine nine dollars
a year you get this the very
greatest you know beverage vessels look
this magnificent piece of vessel check
it out it is just great you get that for
$99 and and all sorts of other goodies
also subscribe to iTunes and YouTube
when you do that and you actually get to
see our Sunday special and listen to our
Sunday special we're having on Tai Lopez
this week an upcoming which have a bunch
of great guests I can't wait to announce
to you as they come up like really
awesome guests so check that out we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so speaking of Hollywood being out
of touch My Luck Eunice who is a very
big star although she's in a new movie
with Kate McKenna and that's basically a
spy thriller no one will see it's
getting terrible reviews but I'm sure
that's just because of sexism it's not
because it's a bad movie it's because of
sexism because it has two female leads
and what what I do love the idea that
what women really want to watch at the
movies is women I don't know where where
this idea came from in Hollywood that
all women want to do is watch Eat Pray
Love or that they want to watch an
action movie with women
I don't maybe maybe I'm just biased here
I don't know a single woman like not one
who is desperate to watch an action
flick with a female lead I was under the
impression that most women kind of like
men I was under the impression that they
would rather watch Tom Cruise run around
then watch My Luck unis run around most
men would rather watch Tom Cruise run
around and watch my lacuna strung around
because Tom Cruise runs faster than my
luck unis and there's this sort of
Hollywood absurdity where you have these
90 pound women or kicking 300-pound guys
in the chest and guys like flying
through glass windows when in reality
the 300-pound man would take the kick
and then take the woman by the leg and
chocolate right Hollywood has these
bizarre notions I will I will survey the
only woman in the room Sonya would you
prefer to watch my like unison an action
flick or Tom Cruise in an action flick
Daniel Craig okay that's fair right okay
did Tom Cruise old but the annual Craig
is not old by the way I just saw the
Mission Impossible flick Tom Cruise is
58 years old man that dude is in crazy
shape that is wild but Daniel Craig fair
enough right when they talk about let's
make Jane bond as opposed to James Bond
yeah try that you know much money it
will make it the box office $0 they
tried this with atomic blonde in which
they basically substituted Charlize
Theron for a man in like every possible
way including 11 lesbian sex scenes and
the movie wildly underperform because it
turns out that when you watch a female
character you'd actually like her to be
have certain indicative female
stereotypical attributes that are just
not present if you could substitute a
man in for that part there's not staking
of a lesbian in a film that would
actually be productive and useful but if
you could substitute a man into the part
like directly without changing a single
line of dialogue it's very difficult to
see why people should go see that film
as opposed to seeing Daniel Craig in the
same film okay but all of that is beside
the point milah Kunis is in this new
movie and she's being interviewed about
about why she is
pro-choice and the answer to why she's
pro-choice is because she legitimately
has never met a pro-lifer now I don't
know any Republican in America who's
never met a pro-choice er I seriously
don't I talked to hundreds of thousands
of Republicans right I don't understand
where why it is that so many folks on
the Left have never met a pro-lifer
except that every view on the right must
be castigated as horrible and evil
here's my lacuna stalking on a podcast
marc maron about why it is that she is
pro-choice I was gonna always donate to
Planned Parenthood anyway yeah but I
will say this here's what happens so
there's an address that was listed
online that's not necessarily my
personal address but it's listed as if
it's my personal address and so then
people started giving donations to the
opposing side I didn't even know there
was one okay I don't to promote it
whatever it is yeah I didn't even know
there was one you legitimately didn't
even know that there's a pro-life
movement in the country like you didn't
know that there's a group of people who
think that you shouldn't kill babies in
the womb that sort of insular thinking
is exactly the culture gap that is
really ripping the country apart I think
the culture gap that's tearing the
country apart is not a racial culture
gap I think the racial stuff is is
almost a weird overlay on top of
cultural battles that are being fought
and this is one of the things that the
left doesn't understand they think that
when President Trump is appealing to
quote-unquote white culture but he's
really appealing to is is a racial
culture but he's really appealing to is
a group particularly of white people in
the middle of the country who have a gap
not with black people so much as with
other white people on the coasts there's
this weird idea on the left that there's
this thing called whiteness I was
listening to a podcast with my friend
Jane Costin over at box.com and choose
doing the podcast with Ezra Klein it's
it's the weeds podcast it's kind of
interesting basically the three people
who are on Torres recline who is
sometimes thoughtful on the left and
sometimes just wrong in your siteís and
Jane who I think is thoughtful and Dylan
Matthews who's basically the Leroy
Jenkins of that show like he just kind
of runs in randomly and shouts Leroy
Jenkins and nobody knows why he's just
spouting the typical lefty line in any
case they were talking about all of this
talk lately about racism and whiteness
and and why it is that ripping on white
people is different from ripping on
black people and their suggestion was
that you can't be racist really against
white people you can only be racist
against black people was sort of the
implication of the show and they were
suggesting that
is a concept that has some merit that
there is this thing called whiteness and
what is whiteness well as a recline says
that what whiteness really is it's the
stuff white people kind of do
stereotypically now if you applied that
same logic to blackness of course you'd
be a racist but if you do it to
whiteness and it's okay but the truth is
that Ezra Klein is wrong as a recline is
wrong the culture gap in the country is
not between quote unquote whiteness and
quote unquote blackness the culture gap
is between secularists and religious it
is between left and right it is between
certain value systems it is not between
people of different colors and in a
second I want to read you a little bit
of this piece from my friends David
French which really hits this on the
nose and really speaks to the gap that
is emerged between the media and the
rest of the country and Hollywood and
the rest of the country okay so we
played that clip of my lacuna so my
lacunae says she's never heard of
anybody who's pro-life in the country
Jim Acosta who is completely out of
touch with the middle of the country and
every so often the middle of the country
sort of rears its ugly head and they go
oh let's send somebody out there as
though there's Steve Irwin in the
outback like oh look at these people
these crazy people living in the middle
of that in the country wow I didn't know
what accent that was but it's sort of an
Australian accent in any case they they
treat people in the middle of the
country white people middle of the
country as foreigners to do there
they're gonna go and they're going to
examine that culture miked I think going
to see what the stingrays do out here
well that is really the attitude that
divides the country so here's what David
French writes he says Klein brought up
the old stuff we talked about this
podcast of Ezra Klein and Jane Costin
and Dylan Matthews over Vox he says at
that point climed brought up the BLA the
old blog stuff white people like I
remember it well as the son of a rural
South of the rural South who spent some
time living in prosperous quarters of
progressive America Manhattan Cambridge
Massachusetts Philadelphia Center City I
thought it was funny
it satirized a highly specific kind of
white American life one largely alien to
my existence the white people in that
blog were nothing like the white people
I grew up with and that brings me to the
subject I think has to be discussed
right alongside race when discussing
American life and American politics the
great white culture war and basically
what French argues is that when you have
all these people like Milo Kunis you say
you know I don't care about whiteness in
the country whiteness can decline at any
rate I want it to decline at and that's
totally fine
is it perspective with which like I
don't care about race it doesn't make
any difference to me I don't care what
color people are I'm Jewish yeah and
even if I were white I wouldn't care I
mean in certain cases I am perceived as
white I don't care how many white people
are in the country versus how many black
people are in the country I care about
the stuff inside their heads as stuff I
actually care about but the point that
French is making is when people on the
Left talk about whiteness people like my
lacuna is presumably or people like Jim
Acosta or people on the left in these
little bubbles they're really not
talking about whiteness they're talking
about white people in the middle of the
country they don't like because my
lacuna s-- is not giving up her job
anytime soon for a person of color and
neither is Jim Acosta right they're
talking about a certain white cultural
elitism that pervades the coasts and
that they feel they're in agreement on
as long as they pander to a bunch of
people of color that's what they're
really talking about so when they rip on
whiteness they're not ripping on the
whiteness of Portland Oregon what
they're really ripping on is the
whiteness of Tennessee but they're
really ripping on is the whiteness of
Texas which by the way is going to be
predominantly Hispanic in the very near
future so this is this is really the
culture war that is being fought right
now and it's because people fail to take
into account anything remotely
resembling a multiple regression
analysis that you end up with these
simplistic takes on politics so a
multiple regression analysis for people
who didn't take stats courses in college
when you are determining how many
factors lead to a particular outcome you
can basically create unions with cement
with an Excel spreadsheet basic
statistical analysis you can create
formulas that try to correlate a
particular phenomenon with the factors
leading to the phenomenon so for example
you want to figure out which factors
lead to being an NBA player and so you
you determine what percentage of black
people are NBA players what percentage
of tall people are NBA players what
percentage of athletic people are NBA
players how do each of these things
factor into playing in the NBA and that
multiple regression analysis will show
you the blackness has very little to do
with playing in the NBA but being very
tall does have something to do and
athleticism has something to do with
playing in the NBA well you may look at
the NBA and say Oh blackness is an asset
in the NBA that's not correct height and
athleticism are assets in the NBA how do
you know because you actually did a
multiple regression analysis well if
you're looking at the gaps in this
country people on the Left see disparity
and the first thing they do is they leap
to race the reality is that we have to
look at all of the cross-cutting other
factors before we go to race because
race has a lot a race is a secondary
characteristic it's just the color of
your skin really and the attempt by the
left to blame everything on racism to
say that every inequality between groups
is rooted an American bias and racism if
you didn't go there first I would
suggest that you rule out and more
obvious factors that could be
contributing to those statistical
disparities so for example there's the
sweet that came out about the wealth gap
it now has some tens of thousands of
retweets and it says white people get
fifty thousand dollar checks from their
elderly grandparents black people are
buying their elderly grandparents
groceries this is the wealth gap the
suggestion of course being that white
America is racist and that's why black
people are poor now is it true the
historical racism has a lot to do with
the continuation of a wealth gap
particularly in terms of home ownership
and historic well of course that's true
of course that's true but if you're
looking at the rates of progress in
America that has very little to do with
historical racism rates of progress in
America are much more tied to individual
decision-making and you can tell this
with a multiple regression analysis it
has much more to do with choosing to
marry the woman who's going to bear your
children has much more to do with
getting a job and finishing high school
I think these are the things that make
you wealthy in America the fact that the
left has this flattering view of itself
where it is the sigh it's on the side of
everything that is good and true and not
in favor of quote unquote whiteness what
they really mean is we're not in favor
of the white people in the middle of the
country those are the bad guys were the
good white people and we can show you
where the good white people by
criticizing other white people but not
giving up anything that we actually hold
dear in these little enclaves of wealth
and power and privilege and that's the
reason you have this cultural gap in the
country that is widening every single
day it is widening all the time okay so
I want to talk about a couple of stories
that the media have been ignoring and
then we'll get to a thing I like and a
thing I hate first there's this story
that it's really amazing and the media
are covering the story but they're
missing
I think the punchline okay so it turns
out there's an Islamic man who was
arrested last week at a New Mexico
compound where eleven children were
abused he was training the children's
commit school shootings according to
newly released court documents now if
you look at the headlines today all of
the headlines are man was training
children to commit school shootings
there was a big factor that was missing
from the headlines okay so this is a
case where the media's failure to do a
multiple regression analysis is kind of
obvious right what they will say is
while this just shows that the culture
of gun ownership in the United States is
leading to school shootings well maybe
it has more to do with the ideology of
the person who's training children to
shoot up schools maybe it has to do the
fact that guy was a radical Islamist the
court filings say surah jebin wash was
conducting weapons training with assault
rifles at the compound near the Colorado
border or 11 hungry children were found
in filthy conditions his father by the
way is a guy named Suraj will Hajj he
was named by prosecutors as an
unindicted co-conspirator in the 1993
World Trade Center bombing ironically
that is also a person I believe who's
been linked Suraj mahadji if I'm not
mistaken he was named by Linda Sarsour
as is as as one of her mentors if I'm
not mistaken so Linda Sarsour of course
is one of the leaders of the women's
March and she is just a delight she
praised Imam C Raja Hajj just a few
years ago so she's a wonderful person
maybe it has more to do with ideology
than gun ownership the media won't tell
you that instead they will headline with
the idea that is the guns it will also
not headline the the fact that the
parklands Broward County school system
knew full well that the shooter in
Parkland had gone to them multiple times
asking for help they turned him down
then he wouldn't shot up a school
instead we'll get a non multiple
regression analysis in which we do not
learn the other factors leading to the
school shooting in Parkland instead we
learned that it was really about the
guns now the truth is according to the
local 10 News in that area throughout
the more than 15 years this shooter
spent in the Broward County School
System staff members reported violent
outbursts and antisocial behavior others
noted periods where his behavior and
academic performance markedly improved
the document was originally redacted but
an electronic copy made public by the
school districts contain information
underneath the blackout portions and
what it found is that he actually kept
going in there for help and they kept
sending him away until he shot up a
school but that's not the story that the
media will actually tell you today the
story that the media will tell you is
that it's all about the guns the media
have an interest people have an interest
in simplifying complex questions down to
the most obvious basics but you actually
have to determine which factors how many
factors are important in determining
cause and effect you can't just say
there's a disparity or there's an event
and it happened because of this thing
you instead have to look
all of the factors that were involved in
it and determine which factors were most
likely to have contributed heavily to
this possible outcome okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so a thing I like today ma'am
this is it may be my wife's favorite
movie she loves this movie and the score
too it is really great as well this of
course is Pride and Prejudice with Keira
Knightley Keira Knightley is a she's
kind of an interesting actress I've I've
always I've never been a fan of hers but
then every time I see her actually
perform I think she's actually quite
good in this in Pride and Prejudice she
is terrific and the movie is just
beautifully produced so you should go
check it out it's a very romantic film
if you're married dudes this is a film
to show your wife I'll go check out
Pride and Prejudice with Keira Knightley
this one's ability nears old maybe
something like that very good movie in
an era when marrying a rich man was the
most a woman could hope for Elizabeth
Bennett was way ahead of her time I
singled you out as the companion of my
future life sir I cannot accept you okay
so it's really it's really great it's
really well done and it's and the score
of it is terrific as well go check it
out
really really worthwhile watch okay time
for a quick thing that I hate
and so over the past 48 hours Israel has
been hit with legitimately 150 rockets
from the Gaza Strip now you will not see
this in the media speaking of stories
you won't see covered in the media
you'll never see this in the media
because when Jews are being shot at by
Palestinians it's not a story when Jews
shoot back at Palestinians it's a story
so when Israel goes in with overwhelming
military might and attempts to knock out
comma space ha's which invariably are
located in civilian areas because Hamas
knows that they will make a headline
every time a civilian is killed that's
the story that makes you NN right see
and I've said it before CNN a lot of the
mainstream media they are Hamas is
propaganda outlets when it comes to this
sort of stuff it's disgusting okay
here's some actual video of what it
looks like when Rockets are fired
against Israel you're basically given 10
seconds to get to a bomb shelter how
there been 14 people who have been
injured these are these are rockets
being fired into civilian areas there's
not one country on planet earth that
would tolerate this except for Israel
there's not one country on planet earth
that would be as humane as Israel has
been in its response to all of this can
you imagine if Mexico started firing
rockets into San Diego like 150 Rockets
got fired by Mexico and in San Diego you
know how fast we would topple that
government that would take us five
minutes legitimately five minutes the
United States would go in and knock out
the entire government and then replace
it I mean we big when al-qaeda murdered
3,000 Americans we knocked down two
Islamic countries two of them okay when
they killed 3,000 citizens with with
some airplanes okay Israel took a
hundred and fifty rockets over the past
48 hours they did some very specific
targeted pinprick bombing and you watch
that'll be the story right the story
will be the the civilian that was killed
because Hamas plants all of its its
headquarters underneath hospitals here's
what the video actually looks like when
rockets are flying and you have five
seconds to get your kids underground
[Music]
[Applause]
you can see the smoke rising from
another rocket I mean these things are
landing in civilian areas that are
landing in streets the media is biased
the media's bias is never more apparent
than when you see their coverage of this
conflict it is just disgusting the
media's lack of interest in terrorism in
the media's lack of interest in radical
Islamic fanatic murderous ideology is
astonishing and demonstrative of this
particular Marxist view that many of the
media hold that if a country is
prosperous like Israel must be because
it's victimized somebody else like the
Palestinians it can't just be that
Palestinian culture is unsuccessful by
and large because they are electing
terrorists to lead their government in
Kumasi stam and in Palestinian Authority
land and that those governments and then
stealing hundreds of millions of dollars
to use for terrorism and align their own
pockets the media's coverage of these
issues is just abysmal abysmal ok well
we will be back here tomorrow with all
the latest i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing